to many in india and beyond to listen to
lata mangeshkar's songs is to hear the
voice of a nation
she could reach the highest notes
[Music]
conquer any range
unfettered by genre or style
[Music]
she expressed the emotions of famous
bollywood actors on screen
with a voice often described as ageless
and pure
[Music]
born in the city of indore in 1929 lata
mangeshkar was the eldest of five
children
her father was a classical singer and
theater actor who died when she was 13.
that was also when she made her debut on
radio and on screen as a singer and an
actor in minor roles
[Music]
she was a woman who was struggling and
she entered a male dominated industry in
the 1940s and made a mark by maintaining
an utmost dignity
after india lost the border war to china
in 1962
lata mangeshkar sang the nation's most
memorable tribute for its fallen
soldiers
legend has it that when she sang
india's first prime minister jawaharlal
[Music]
over decades she became one of india's
most prolific artists
[Music]
with thousands of songs lip synced by
actors across india in dozens of
languages
versatility is unprecedented it's
unparalleled i think that the beautiful
pristine quality of her voice is is so
rare and unique which is why you know
she
almost you know captured the imagination
of the of the entire nation it's almost
as if she unified india in a way because
there was no language no regional
language in india that she that she did
not sing in
in 2001 she was given india's high
civilian award the pirate threatener
eight years later france presented her
with its hired civilian award the legion
of honor
for more than 70 years her career
spanned the entire spectrum of hindi
cinema
a feat unparalleled by her peers
[Music]
[Music]
the daughter of india was 92.
[Music]
i